chers collègues j'ai le plaisir de
saluer dans la tribune d'honneur une
délégation conduite par Madame Brigitte
brocollettage présidente du conseil
national de Monaco elle est accompagnée
par notre collègue Dominique Estrosi
président du groupe inter parlementaire
d'amitié France Monaco cette visite
s'inscrit dans le cadre des échanges
réguliers entre le Seda et la
Principauté de Monaco dans les liens
avec la France ont si étroit en
particulier pour nos concitoyens du
département des Alpes-Maritimes qui
travaillent quotidiennement nombreux
cette visite aura permis d'évoquer les
nombreux sujets intéressants directement
les relations franco Monégasques en
particulier le logement les transports
l'environnement
l'environnement dans le domaine dans
lequel la Principauté est à
l'avant-garde mais aussi des
négociations avec l'Union européenne
pour la conclusion éventuelle d'un
accord d'association nous souhaitons à
nos amis Monégasques de fructuer
échanges en formulant le vœu cette
session de travail attire parlementaire
contribue à renforcer davantage les
relations entre nos deux états
[Applaudissements]
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
des nuits d'une rare violence sont
marquées notre pays depuis une semaine
les mères les élus locaux en première
ligne ont été encore une fois le rempart
de la République
aux côtés de nos forces de l'ordre de
nos sapeurs-pompiers et de nos polices
municipales
la mort d'un jeune est évidemment un
drame mais rien ne peut justifier les
émeutes les agressions et menaces contre
les élus le pillage l'incendie de nos
mairie de nos écoles de le commissariat
ou de commerce
l'ordre républicain doit être établi et
les enseignements de ce qui s'est passé
devront être tirés
le Sénat s'y engagera pleinement dans sa
mission temps de législateur comme de
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
afin que soit faite la lumière sur ces
événements qu'on soit tiré les
enseignants les enseignements et que
nous puissions faciliter faciliter pour
nos élus locaux le redressement de
situation aujourd'hui insupportable
enfin mes chers collègues je veux en
autre nom à tous apporter notre soutien
à tous ceux citoyens commerçants élus
locaux force de sécurité de secours qui
ont été visés ou directement atteints
par ces violences voilà la déclaration
que je souhaitais faire avant que nous
abordions notre ordre du jour notre
ordre du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
notre séance est retransmise en
direction Public Sénat et sur d'autres
sites au nom du bureau du Sénat appelle
chacun de vous mes chers collègues à
observer des valeurs qui me paraissent
essentielles le respect des uns et des
autres et une valeur aussi pratique qui
s'appelle le respect du temps de parole
la parole est à notre collègue et Xavier
yakovelli pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocrates progressistes
et indépendant
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre quatre jours de
violence et d'émeutes quatre jours de
vol et de pillage 4 jours d'agression et
d'incendie qu'est-ce que cette situation
dit de notre société
j'ai vu avec PN le départ de band dans
lequel je suis élu le quartier dans
lequel j'ai grandi et où je vis devenir
dans quelques heures le chant de
bataille de quelques voyous
avant tout permettez-moi de saluer les
mers des Hauts-de-Seine de toute
sensibilité politique et à travers eux
l'ensemble des maires de France qui ont
été en première ligne comme toujours les
élus locaux n'ont pas failli
et ils ont même été et éviter que tout
s'enflamme davantage bien sûr il y a eu
un drame la mort d'un jeune de 17 ans
qui nous a forcément ému et choqué la
justice fera son travail elle le fait
déjà VIP et elle le fait bien mais la
justice ce n'est pas la vengeance la
justice ce n'est pas attaqué et blessée
près de 800 policiers gendarmes et
pompiers la justice ce n'est pas
détruire et incendié des crèches nos
écoles nos bibliothèques et nos mairies
la justice ce n'est pas pillée les
magasins et même brûler nos voitures
la justice ce n'est pas menacée la vie
des élus et de leur famille comme ce fut
le cas pour notre collègue Jean Brun
qui peut encore accepter que certains
prônent le chaos et l'insurrection
permanente pour gagner un pouvoir qui
n'ont pas réussi à obtenir par les urnes
les auteurs de ces attaques ne sont pas
des simples jeunes la jeunesse de notre
pays celle de nos quartiers ne méritent
pas cette définition son décrassantes
majorité travail elle est courageuse
elle est audacieuse elle est solidaire
et elle se bat au quotidien pour prendre
cette ascenseur social non ces individus
ne sont ni les insurgés ni des insoumis
ils ont fait le choix de la violence non
pas fatalité mais par facilité face à
cette violence il nous faut donc de la
fermeté de l'ordre et de la justice il
est temps Madame la première ministre de
refonder notre pacte républicain autour
des valeurs de solidarité de mérite
d'ordre et de travail d'avoir ce sursaut
civil qui est nécessaire pour notre pays
cela ne se fera pas sans les élus locaux
qui ont plus que jamais besoin de la
République besoin de l'État à leur côté
madame la Première ministre quels moyens
le gouvernement compte mettre en place
pour les soutenir je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole des cabanes
la première ministre vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Xavier yakovelli
la mort tragique d'un jeune homme de 17
ans dans votre département à Nanterre a
provoqué une émotion légitime dans notre
pays et je sais qu'elle a été partagée
dans cette émission mais cette émotion
ne peut pas servir de prétexte pour des
violences inacceptables pour viser les
symboles de la République brûler des
mairies des commissariats ou des écoles
pour piller des magasins pour cibler des
élus et j'ai de nouveau une pensée pour
le maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses et pour sa
famille
avec chacun d'entre vous j'en suis sûr
je veux à nouveau dire mon soutien aux
policiers gendarmes policier municipaux
et sapeurs-pompiers engagé avec courage
et professionnalisme je veux saluer la
mobilisation des magistrats et des
greffiers je veux dire au maire et aux
élus qui sont en première ligne que nous
sommes à leur côté notre première
priorité notre priorité absolue c'est le
retour de l'ordre républicain notre
stratégie s'est appuyée sur quatre
piliers d'abord la mobilisation des
forces de l'ordre avec jusqu'à 45000
policiers et gendarmes sur le terrain
ensuite la fermeté de la réponse pénale
pour qu'il n'y ait aucune impunité à
l'égard des auteurs de violence
troisième pilier la responsabilisation
des réseaux sociaux et enfin un rappel
nécessaire de la responsabilité et de
l'autorité parentale car les auteurs
sont jeunes voire très jeunes
une décrue de la violence a été observée
ces dernières nuits et la situation
devient redevient pratiquement normale
bien sûr avec le ministre de l'Intérieur
Gérald Darmanin nous restons extrêmement
vigilants et nous adaptons très
progressivement notre dispositif de
sécurité
monsieur le sénateur yakovelli si
l'urgence est au rétablissement de
l'ordre républicain nous sommes d'ores
et déjà mobilisés auprès des élus et des
mers pour les accompagner dans la
réparation de leur ville le Président de
la République l'a dit hier nous
accompagnerons les élus touchés
notamment au plan financier et en
accélérant les procédures pour réouvrir
au plus vite les équipements publics et
nous répondrons présents pour les
habitants pour les commerçants les
artisans pour toutes les victimes de ces
violences monsieur le sénateur si
l'urgence est au rétablissement de
l'ordre républicain
cette crise appelle des réponses de fond
elle nécessite un diagnostic partagé et
une action collective de l'État et de
l'ensemble des partis prenantes et je ne
doute pas que le Sénat y prendra toute
sa part je vous remercie merci
la parole est à notre collègue Jérôme
Durin pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues la semaine
dernière un enfant est mort cette mort
est tragique et nous pensons à la
douleur de la famille Naël cette mort a
eu des conséquences collectives
terribles des quartiers se sont embrasés
partout en France en Île-de-France dans
de grandes villes comme dans de plus
petites communes nos forces de l'ordre
ont rétabli le calme et il faut les en
remercier une colère au début
compréhensible s'est transformé
progressivement en N aveugle propice au
pillage les sénateurs les sénateurs et
sénatrices socialistes ont évidemment
appelé au calme la République ne peut
pas exister sans ordre mais elle ne peut
pas reposer que sur l'ordre le concours
Lépine des postures autoritaires nous
laisse entre la colère et les bêtises
deux claques et au lit une cagnotte par
ci une milice par là une dose de
régression ethnique c'est l'incendie
après l'incendie
la question que je souhaite vous poser
s'adresse à vous puisque vous êtes aux
responsabilités mais nous avons tous à y
répondre une grande partie de la
jeunesse paix aujourd'hui notre échec
collectif à faire rayonner la République
nous n'avons pas désamorcé les bombes
plantées dans les fondations de notre
société les causes en sont multiples et
variées certains refusent constipent
mais si nous ne nous posons pas les
bonnes questions nous ne trouverons pas
les justes réponse les questions qui
sont posées sont légion la politique de
la ville les discriminations le rôle des
maires difficile en première ligne je
veux pour ma part vous interroger sur ce
qui a mis le feu aux poudres les
relations entre police et population fin
2020 Beauveau de la sécurité était
convoqué sur ces sujets si des choses
utiles en sont sorties pour la police et
nous avons voté la loopnie force et de
constater que toute la population est
loin d'être réconciliée avec sa police
seul le ministre comment comptez-vous
désormais améliorer concrètement cette
question des rapports entre police et
population
pour vous répondre
la parole est au ministre de l'intérieur
des outres Gérald Darmanin monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les créateurs monsieur le
sénateur du Rhin
à Nanterre il y a eu un drame et je
crois que les premiers mots que j'ai pu
avoir comme ministre de l'intérieur
comme la première ministre évidemment
était des mots de transparence
d'équilibre parce que si on soutient les
forces de l'ordre et vous je pense que
vous voyez et vous soutenez également
les forces de l'ordre comme nous le
faisons il faut savoir dire les choses
et ne pas mentir aux Français la justice
passe ce policier qui a toujours la
présomption d'innocence je souhaite le
souligner a été mis en garde à vue a été
mis en examen il existe donc des indices
graves et concordants comme quoi il sera
responsable de la mort en dehors de la
loi de la République en dehors de la
déontologie de ce jeune homme il est en
détention provisoire je veux aussi en
disant ça avoir une pensée pour les 800
policiers gendarmes et sapeurs-pompiers
blessés pendant ces quatre jours
d'émeutes et qui ont été courageux et à
la hauteur de ce que la nation leur
offre comme confiance et je veux ici le
souligner
bien sûr on peut toujours améliorer le
travail de la police et de la
gendarmerie monsieur le sénateur et
évidemment il y a toujours des efforts à
faire mais est-ce que le comportement de
la police comme je n'entends parfois
depuis plusieurs heures est-ce la seule
réponse aux difficultés que nous
connaissons et s la seule réponse aux
violences si c'est le cas pourquoi on a
attaqué des sapeurs-pompiers il ne
contrôle personne il sauve tout le monde
pourquoi on a attaqué des polices
municipales
78 poses de police municipales la police
municipale ne sont pas sur la même
consigne que pour la police pour la
gendarmerie nationale pourquoi on
attaque des élus est-ce que ces élus ont
tutoyé ces délinquants ont-ils été
particulièrement discriminants pourquoi
ont-ils attaqué des médiathèques des
écoles pourquoi il piller des commerces
ne trouvons pas des excuses toujours
dans le comportement de la police si
elle doit se réformer
elle doit aussi
si elle doit se réformer monsieur Durand
et je sais que j'ai pas la républicain
et doit aussi être d'éviter être un bouc
émissaire pour se poser les bonnes
questions
merci
que durant vous avez quelques secondes
vous n'avez pas répondu à ma question je
vous la poserais en édition tout à
l'heure alors que des vents mauvais des
vents sécurité souffle alors que
certains des syndicats policiers
s'égarent dans des tracts inquiétants
nous vous demandons Monsieur le Ministre
de tenir bon sur les principes
républicains de la police de la
République
la parole est à notre collègue mère pour
le groupe du Rassemblement démocratique
et social européen vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adressait à madame la Première
ministre comme l'a dit le président de
la République hier devant plus de 200
mères même si le calme est revenu on ne
peut pas faire comme si rien ne s'était
passé ce qui s'est passé était
prévisible pour certains un premier
diagnostic avait été porté dès 2017 par
l'appel de Grigny et après son plan en
2018 Jean-Louis Borloo a tiré de nouveau
la larme l'an dernier certains points
ont été repris comme les cités
éducatives de nous avions salué
l'intérêt avec la mission sur la
délinquance des mineurs du Sénat le
dédoublement des classes de cpce1 en
repérer plus semblent aussi porter ses
fruits mais madame le Premier ministre
peut-on sérieusement dire que 75% du
plan Burlot a été mise en œuvre
on ne peut pas demander davantage au
maire déjà beaucoup exposés ce n'est pas
non plus le président de la République
seul à l'Elysée qui pourra régler du
règlement les problèmes ni croire que le
rappel alors des parents certes
nécessaires sera suffisant c'est en
conjuguant toutes nos forces que l'on
s'en sortira état Région Département
knaf CNAM knav Action Logement chambre
consulaire Caisse des Dépôts monde du
HLM secteur privé associatif c'est la
grande coalition proposée par Jean-Louis
Borloo chevet des piliers fondamentaux
que sont la justice l'ordre public la
jeunesse la santé l'habitat l'énergie la
lutte contre le dérèglement climatique
il nous faut un chef de fil pour chacun
des 19 programmes du plan Borlo et un
pilote pour le suivi régulier l'or n'est
plus au rapport d'experts leur est à
l'action
vous avez dit hier madame la Première
ministre est à l'écoute des propositions
et bien elles sont faites comment
comptez-vous maintenant effectivement
les mettre en œuvre
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué chargé de la ville et
du Logement monsieur Klein merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur fialer oui vous avez raison le
message doit être porté par l'Ensemble
de notre pays d'abord un message pour le
retour au calme et c'était le la
première des priorités et ensuite comme
vous l'avez dit nous devons continuer à
travailler ensemble pour les quartiers
populaires vous rappelez le travail mené
par Jean-Louis Borlo et son rapport un
certain nombre d'entre vous il y avait
d'ailleurs contribué moi-même j'ai
participé à son écriture et je peux vous
assurer on va pas peser ça au trébucher
mais la réalité c'est que un grand
nombre des propositions de ce rapport
ont été mis en oeuvre la première c'est
la relance de l'Agence Nationale pour le
renouvellement urbain lors du
quinquennat précédent nous sommes passés
de 5 milliards à 12 milliards pour les
quartiers populaires ça veut dire que
tous les acteurs vont dépenser près de
50 milliards pour ces quartiers avec un
retour le financement de l'État qui
était complètement sorti dans le
quinquennat précédent les deux
quinquennat précédents du financement de
la rue et c'est à regretter oui les
cités éducatives de censité éducative et
le président de la République
l'annonçait à Marseille la
généralisation des cités éducatives oui
les dédoublement des classes de cours
préparatoires de C1 de grande section et
maintenant le président là aussi dit à
Marseille la scolarisation la plus
précoce notamment dans les quartiers
populaires madame la Première ministre
lorsqu'elle était ministre de l'Emploi a
lancé les emplois francs et c'est une un
grand succès plus de 100 000 enfants et
là aussi c'était dans le rapport Borlo
la culture au cœur de nos quartiers
regardez le nombre de projets des mots
l'augmentation de ces projets dans nos
quartiers regarder les microfolies qui
se développent dans nos quartiers
regardez le passeport mené par la
ministre des Sports qui se met en place
dans l'ensemble de nos quartiers oui il
faut continuer et dans les mesures
quartiers 2030 on continuera mais là la
réponse l'urgence aujourd'hui c'est bien
de continuer à la Concorde au retour au
calme et c'est ce que nous faisons avec
le gouvernement et à l'ensemble des élus
locaux et je vous remercie monsieur
Fiolet à vous avez quelques secondes
oui monsieur le ministre je vous ai bien
entendu écouter il faut vraiment qu'on
ait un pilote dans de tous ces actions
que chaque chantier soit aussi avec un
chef de fil parce que c'est ensemble que
l'on pourra s'en sortir
merci
la parole est à notre collègue Daniel
Breuillet pour le groupe écologie
solidarité et territoire de la parole
monsieur le ministre Naël a été abattu à
bout portant il avait 17 ans il est mort
et c'est inacceptable le domicile du
maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses a été attaqué
mettant danger la vie de son épouse et
de ses enfants c'est un qualifiable
chaque jour habitant et commerçant élus
et agent des services publics font le
bilan des dégâts dans leur ville
réparent ce qu'ils peuvent et disent
leurs interrogations et leur refus de la
violence les mers font face comme
toujours monsieur le ministre qui peut
croire qu'il suffit d'appeler à
l'autorité à la répression à la mise en
cause des familles pour tourner la page
nous devons comprendre les causes ne pas
comprendre c'est se rendre incapable de
traiter les problèmes ouvrons les yeux
et regardons ces quartiers qui malgré
les milliards consacrés à la rénovation
urbaine reste souvent des quartiers de
relégation on a mis beaucoup d'argent
dans le bâti mais pas assez dans
l'humain quelle faute d'avoir enterré le
plan Borlo 57% d'enfants vivent sous le
seuil de pauvreté 18% vraiment solo deux
enfants sur trois ne partiront pas en
vacances dans les quartiers prioritaires
les hommes naissent libre égaux dans
notre République mais c'est moins vrai
quand on est pauvre noir ou arabe
ouvrons les yeux sur le racisme et les
discriminations qui rongent notre
société comment accepter qu'une grande
partie de la jeunesse et de la police se
regardent en ennemi c'est ce qui a fait
courir c'est ce qui a fait courir j'ai y
être bounaï mouitine vers se
transformateur électrique en 2005 le
racisme et la peur sont toujours là pas
chez tous bien sûr mais toujours là
quand même monsieur le ministre
convoquant l'intelligence collective au
chevet de notre République malade celle
de tous ceux qui croient que la promesse
républicaine est là pour tous la
promesse républicaine a trop souvent
quitté nos quartiers comment dire aux
enfants des quartiers en difficulté
qu'ils sont toutes et tous les filles et
les fils de la République disaient le
président Chirac en 2005 monsieur le
ministre prendrez-vous l'initiative et
la responsabilité d'un travail collectif
indispensable ou reculerons-nous une
fois de plus devant l'obstacle
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste de la cohésion des
territoires monsieur Béchu
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur broyer
ces émeutes se sont pas celles de 2005
vous avez utilisé les mots du président
Chirac vous avez convoqué ce qui a été à
l'origine d'une politique de la ville de
la création de la rue et de choses qui
ont été partagées de manière unanime
553 communes ont été victimes de
dégradation un titre 169 d'entre elles
ne sont pas en géographie politique de
la ville dans 120 d'entre elles il y a
moins de 3000 habitants qui vivent en
qpv résumer ça au sujet des quartiers
c'est commencer à se tromper sur
l'analyse vous avez évoqué le bilan et
le fait qu'il fallait qu'on ouvre les
yeux je nous invite à ouvrir les yeux
sur les 838 policiers gendarmes et
pompiers blessés depuis le début des
émeutes je nous invite à ouvrir les yeux
sur les 2500 bâtiments publics qui ont
subi des incendies je nous invite à
ouvrir des yeux sur les prêts de 4000
interpellés avec une moyenne d'âge de 17
ans
ouvrir les yeux c'est se demander
comment des enfants de 13 à 14 ans peut
se retrouver la nuit avec des bidons
d'essence dans les mains à incendier des
bâtiments publics ouvrir les yeux c'est
se demander comment des mortiers
d'artifice peuvent être utilisés pour
viser comment on peut tirer avec un œuf
mm sur un policier à Nîmes comment
certains peuvent devant cette situation
non pas appeler à l'autorité mais
refuser d'appeler au calme si on ouvre
les yeux là-dessus on peut parler de la
suite la suite c'est quoi la suite c'est
prendre un minimum de temps avant le
fait que chacun ressorte du placard la
suggestion qu'il avait faite lors de la
dernière élection présidentielle pour
regarder ce que cette géographie
entraîne on ne peut pas imaginer que le
sujet c'est seulement un problème
d'argent public et de milliards d'euros
et on ne peut pas non plus penser que on
peut résumer ce débat à celui des
allocations familiales
surtout ces sujets prendre le temps du
diagnostic pour ensuite être capable
d'agir c'est nécessaire et laissez-moi
vous dire une chose
stigmatiser les quartiers c'est laisser
penser que ils sont enfermés de manière
immuable il y a dans ces quartiers des
gens qui en sont sortis il y en a
d'autres qui sont rentrés on n'est pas
sur une logique de photos on est sur une
logique d'évolution et si on ne prend
pas ça en compte on se trompe là aussi
sur le diagnostic
mais si la parole
et maintenant au président Claude malure
pour le gros plus indépendants
République et territoire
madame la Première ministre les
violences de ces derniers jours ont été
condamnés par la quasi-totalité des
formations politiques seul une fois de
plus l'une d'entre elles s'en est
exemptées en refusant d'appeler au calme
les dirigeants de la France soumis à
l'émeute confirme qu'ils sont bien
confirment qu'ils sont bien les ânes de
Troie du séparatisme dans notre pays en
demandant qu'on épargne les
bibliothèques et les écoles ils
autorisent des émeutiers à brûler tout
le reste les commerces les mairies les
maisons des élus ils prétendent défendre
la République leur but est de la faire
tomber depuis un an leur convulsion à
l'Assemblée nationale les discrédites en
discréditant et l'associe le Parlement
cette fois-ci c'est la foi de trop et le
peuple français qu'il prétendent à tort
incarner s'en souviendra longtemps tout
comme son souviendront sans doute leur
plus proche allier politique désormais
honteux de cette alliance contre nature
quand
quant aux protestations faussement
scandalisée des despote de Turquie
d'Algérie ou d'Iran où la répression de
tels émeutes aurait sans aucun doute
fait des dizaines voire des centaines de
victimes permettez-moi de dire qu'elle
donne la nausée enfin la responsabilité
des réseaux antisociaux dans la
propagation des violences est-elle que
le Président de la République a dû les
convoquer à l'Élysée Barack Obama disait
que ces réseaux sont devenus l'une des
principales menaces contre nos
démocraties la preuve est là vous avez
madame la Première ministre condamnée
hier à l'Assemblée l'attitude d'un parti
anti-démocratique sans statut sans
élection interne gouvernée par un
satrape colérique et omnipotent traitant
ses dissidents par la mise à l'écart en
disant qu'il était sorti du champ
républicain et vous avez eu raison
pouvez-vous nous dire aujourd'hui si
vous envisagez de mettre de l'ordre dans
la jungle des plateformes qu'il faut
empêcher d'invoquer à tort la liberté
d'expression pour se rendre complice des
appels à l'émeutes et de l'apologie des
violences et si vous comptez demander à
la ministre des Affaires étrangères de
protester contre les ingérences de
dictateurs qui se permettent de nous
donner des leçons de démocratie
pour vous répondre la parole et à madame
la Première ministre vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Claude madurée monsieur le
Président Claude malgré
le drame de la mort d'un jeune homme de
17 ans ne peut justifier ou excuser
aucune violence
comme la famille du jeune homme comme
les élus du territoire concerné nous ne
demandons qu'une chose la justice et
jamais la justice n'est venue de la
violence
depuis une semaine des actes
inacceptables ont touché plusieurs
centaines de communes les forces de
l'ordre les sapeurs-pompiers et des élus
ont été pris pour cible des mairies des
écoles des équipements publics ont été
vandalisés parfois incendiées des
commerces ont été pillés
face à cette situation nous avons tout
mis en oeuvre pour rétablir l'ordre
républicain autour d'un mot d'ordre le
refus de l'impunité c'est ce que nous
demande les habitants des quartiers
touchés ils sont les premières victimes
de ces violences et les près de 6
millions d'habitants des quartiers n'ont
rien à voir avec quelques milliers de
délinquants
depuis le début des violences près de
4000 personnes ont été interpellées le
Garde des Sceaux a demandé au procureur
une réponse rapide ferme et systématique
pour tous les auteurs et hier soir au
total près de 1000 personnes avec déjà
été présentées à la justice et plus de
350 sont déjà en détention la réponse
pénale a été forte avec notamment des
peines de prison ferme avec des
incarcérations
j'ajoute que le garde des sceaux vient
de diffuser une circulaire sur le
traitement des infractions commises par
les mineurs et les conditions
d'engagement de la responsabilité de
leurs parents
monsieur le Président maluré évidemment
dans cette crise les réseaux sociaux
jouent un rôle important il facilite
parfois l'organisation des violences et
ont souvent une responsabilité dans la
désinhibition des jeunes c'est pourquoi
le gouvernement a demandé à l'ensemble
des plateformes de respecter leurs
obligations de retrait des contenus
illicites et d'être vigilants sur
certaines de leurs fonctionnalités comme
la géolocalisation
par ailleurs nous veillons à ce que les
titulaires des contes ayant participé à
des violences soit identifiées et
poursuivi d'autres réponses de plus long
terme devront être importés c'est
notamment l'objet du règlement européen
sur les services numériques et du projet
de loi pour sécuriser et réguler
l'espace numérique examiner en ce moment
même au Sénat je vous remercie
la parole est maintenant président Bruno
retaillod pour le groupe les
républicains
vous avez raison Madame la première
ministre une mort tragique ne veut pas
servir de prétexte et cette vie de
violence c'est nuit de chaos nous impose
une double exigence une double réponse
la première c'est pour maintenant que la
République servait en
et ensuite pour demain que le
gouvernement ouvre grand les yeux
scellérant parce que dans la mesure où
l'ordre public n'est pas revenu et tant
qu'il ne sera pas rétabli la seule
attitude républicaine responsable cette
révérance c'est de soutenir sans réserve
les forces de l'ordre policiers
nationaux municipaux les
sapeurs-pompiers et les élus bien
entendu
mais
c'est aussi de laisser le gouvernement
travailler et le ministre de l'Intérieur
pour établir l'ordre public l'ordre
républicain en France et nous sommes
d'accord comme vous madame je condamne
aussi ses élus de l'extrême gauche qui
ont choisi leur camp ce camp qui n'est
pas celui de la République ce camp qui
est celui des émeutiers ce sont des
professionnels de l'excuse sociale mais
en l'occurrence ils n'ont strictement
aucune excuse et puis pour l'avenir
l'important pour le gouvernement ce sera
d'ouvrir grand les yeux d'établir le bon
diagnostic d'appeler un chat un émeutier
ça n'est pas un déshérité un délinquant
ça n'est pas une victime alors madame la
Première ministre deux questions la
première quels sont pour vous les causes
de ces émeutes la seconde quelles sont
les remèdes sachant que et vous le savez
très bien la France tranquille
n'accepte plus de passer à la caisse
pour des minorités qui saccagent leur
quartier
parole est abordable la première minute
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
président Bruno Retailleau
face aux violences inexcusable qui ont
touché plusieurs centaines de communes
depuis une semaine
notre premier objectif a été le retour
de l'ordre républicain
nous avons mis en place des moyens
exceptionnels et grâce à la mobilisation
rapide de l'état grâce à l'action et au
courage des forces de l'ordre et des
sapeurs-pompiers grâce à la mobilisation
des élus locaux notamment des mers les
violences connaissent depuis quelques
jours une très forte décrue et la
situation revient progressivement à la
normale
face à la crise nous avions un devoir
d'unité et je veux saluer monsieur le
Président l'attitude républicaine de
votre famille politique pour dénoncer
les violences et appeler au calme
bien sûr monsieur le Président
Retailleau au-delà des réponses
d'urgence nous devons nous pencher sur
les causes profondes de cette crise
sans procrastiner il faudra prendre la
mesure de la complexité de la réalité un
tiers des communes qui ont connu des
violences n'ont pas de quartier
politique de la ville et la moitié des
villes avec des grands ensembles où sont
menés des opérations lourdes de
rénovation urbaine n'ont pas connu de
violence monsieur le Président
Retailleau la quasi-totalité des prêts
de 6 millions d'habitants des quartiers
qui sont les premières victimes de ces
violences expriment leur incompréhension
et leur colère j'ai pu le mesurer
moi-même à Garges-lès-Gonesse à Évry ou
à Bezons ils aspirent à la sécurité ils
aspirent à des services publics de
qualité ils aspirent à être des acteurs
de la République sans distinction
d'origine comme le garantie l'article
premier de notre Constitution
monsieur le Président ensemble nous
devrons nous interroger sur le respect
de l'autorité sur l'exercice de
l'autorité parentale sur l'influence des
réseaux sociaux sur la désinhibie
désinhibition face à la violence ou
encore sur l'efficacité de nos
politiques publiques nous mènerons ces
réflexions sans a priori sans excès ni
caricature sans tabou ni bouc émissaire
nous le ferons avec tous les élites qui
veulent agir et partagent les valeurs de
la République cet ensemble que nous
trouverons des solutions je vous
remercie
le président
oui madame la ministre ma première
ministre le temps nous est compté et les
causes nous les connaissons c'est la
somme de tous nos renoncements c'est la
somme de tous les laisser aller la
faille de l'école la faillite l'autorité
parentale le chaos migratoire bien sûr
le chaos migratoire et aussi une réponse
pénale qui pour les mineurs pour les
mineurs et souvent inadaptés alors
madame le Premier ministre faites la
politique du courage et il y a le
courage de traiter les causes de traiter
les causes et non pas seulement les
conséquences de ces causes par la
politique du carnet de tchèque et alors
si vous avez ce courage nous serons à
vos côtés parce que sans ce courage sans
ce courage les violences reviendront et
sans ce courage sans ce courage la
France rebroulera
merci
la parole est à notre collègue
[Applaudissements]
Amel gaker pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
que le Président Mesdames et messieurs
les ministres chers collègues ma
question s'adresse au ministre de la
transition écologique de la cohésion des
territoires monsieur le ministre quand
la violence augmente cela veut dire que
la politique recule
partout sur le territoire national
museau aussi dans les quartiers l'État a
abandonné ou en tout cas mal assuré une
de ses missions régaliennes celle qui
consiste à préserver la sécurité et la
paix civile il faut en premier lieu
rétablir cette politique prioritaire
dont le succès conditionne la réussite
de toutes les autres l'objectif de la
politique de la ville vous le savez et
de restaurer l'égalité républicaine
entre les quartiers malgré l'engagement
remarquable des acteurs sur le terrain
des élus locaux forces et de constater
que cette promesse n'est plus tenue le
dernier plan en faveur des quartiers qui
a été évoqué de Jean-Louis borelot
plaçant les habitants des quartiers au
cœur de cette politique a
malheureusement été enterré dès sa
présentation depuis on ne voit se
dégager aucune stratégie
vous l'avez dit l'enveloppe en russe a
augmenté du bâtiment terre mais nous
sommes dans le flou sur le plan quartier
2030 et le dernier comité
interministériel des villes n'a accouché
d'aucune annonce il est urgent de faire
preuve de courage politique et
d'envisager enfin une politique sur le
long terme ce qui manque cruellement à
ce pays et cela doit commencer par
regarder la vérité en face établir un
état des lieux de la situation difficile
dans laquelle se trouve ces quartiers en
matière d'éducation d'emploi de santé de
mobilité de sécurité de logement élément
central dans l'intégration des plus
fragiles monsieur le ministre alors où
les quartiers concentre toutes les
inégalités quelles sont vos intentions
pour les quartiers prioritaires à court
terme concrètement quid des contrats de
ville
2024-2030 merci
pour vos réponses la parole est au
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
monsieur
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice hunger
d'abord
Olivier Klein on en dit un mot tout à
l'heure
dire que des propositions ont été
enterrées ça suppose de regarder aussi
ce qui a été fait de manière concrète
depuis quelques années
à la minute où nous parlons sont 350 000
élèves qui sont non des classes des
doublées
dans ces quartiers ce sont deux cités
éducatives c'est la plateforme pour les
stages c'est des dispositifs pour aller
lutter contre les discriminations les
assignations de résidence et de façon
concrète au-delà du passage de 5 à 12
milliards des crédits de la rue c'est
2,5 milliards d'euros qui ont été mis
dans le cadre du plan de relance c'est
une augmentation de 30% des crédits du
programme 147 je vous dis tout ça en
ayant pleinement conscience qu'entre les
chiffres que je donne les montants qui
sont évoqués et la réalité des chantiers
qui ont commencé il peut y avoir des
deltas de la même manière que vous avez
invité à ce que sur les questions de
sécurité on soit capable de répondre la
loi portée par Gérald Darmanin voté par
cette assemblée 8500 policiers
supplémentaires les moyens
supplémentaires pour la justice défendue
par le garde des sceaux 8000 personnels
supplémentaires viennent d'être votées
ils sont en cours de déploiement les 200
brigades de gendarmerie commencent tout
juste à se déployer et on a un décalage
entre ces annonces un constat qui a été
fait et des éléments qui sont annoncés
vous l'avez dit il y a la réflexion
autour de quartier de 1030 je vais pas
reprendre ni les mots de Bruno
Retailleau ni ceux de la première
ministre mais sans m'élever au dessus de
ma condition les miens
en quelque sorte c'est une chance que
nous ayons pu mettre sur pause pour nous
poser la question précise du diagnostic
avant de finaliser ce plan quartier 2030
parce que ce que je crois profondément
et je voulais dire un peu en tant que
ministre vautour beaucoup en tant que
ancien maire d'une ville comptant 7
quartiers politiques de la ville c'est
que si on fait des chèques et qu'on
annonce des plans avant d'aller au fond
de l'analyse des causes nous nous
tromperons et des plans qui valent sur
des années avant de les lancer il faut
qu'on soit certains que nous mettons les
moyens au bon endroit la question de
l'école et la question de l'autorité la
question de la responsabilité parentale
la question de l'association de
l'ensemble des acteurs il faut qu'on les
mette au cœur de nos réflexions tous
ensemble merci beaucoup merci de donner
la parole
Marie-Noël Lindman mais avant lui donner
la parole je voudrais saluer c'est la
prise de Paris depuis 2011 celle qui a
poursuivi dans notre hémicycle et au
sein de la commission des affaires
économiques son investissement sur les
questions de délogements du logement
qu'elle avait eu comme ministre dans
deux gouvernements je la remercie pour
son engagement comme vice-président du
Sénat chez particulièrement apprécié de
l'avoir à mes côtés je voulais saluer
son action comme parlementaire
madame la première Mini il est grand
temps de prendre en compte les
aspiration de tout les Français
elle a des causes multiples des causes
sociales bien sûr d'abord sans doute
mais l'exprime aussi fortement
un grand mécontentement face au
délitement et à l'impuissance de l'État
républicain et de nos services publics
impuissance à faire respecter les droits
le droit
impuissance à assurer l'efficacité des
services publics et leur présence
partout dans nos banlieues comme dans
les zones rurales
incapacité à faire progresser la
promesse républicaine d'égalité de
justice indispensables à la cohésion
nationale voilà le résultat d'une
politique menée depuis 20 ans
vous ne pouvez pas comme vous l'avez
fait après les gilets jaunes après le
mouvement des retraites continuez comme
avant
la grande urgence une urgence vitale et
de redonner force et efficacité à l'État
républicain au service public cela
suppose des moyens la revalorisation
elle écoute des fonctionnaires qui
désespèrent de ne pas pouvoir
correctement assumer leur mission un
exemple parmi tant d'autres tellement
d'actualité
l'éducation nationale qui ne voit
aujourd'hui l'ampleur de la crise
éducative que traverse notre pays qui ne
voit le rôle décisif de l'école publique
en particulier pour ses 20% de jeunes
qui vivent en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté des missions massives postes
non pourvu au concours ou dans les
classes vous ne voulez pas écouter les
enseignants vous faites croire que les
problèmes seraient en voie de résolution
ce n'est absolument pas le cas un grand
plan de redressement des services
publics s'impose et vite
allez-vous madame la Première ministre
l'engager dès cet été dans le projet
budget ne laissez pas la République en
panne agissez
pour vous répondre la parole est obligé
déléguée Charlie de la ville et du
Logement monsieur Klein devait les
paroles merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la sénatrice Marie-Noëlle
Lienemann je me permets moi aussi de
vous saluer madame la saint triste vous
êtes probablement la première ministre
que j'ai rencontré dans ma vie de jeune
et Lucas pour parler des copropriétés
dégradées à Clichy-sous-Bois et ça reste
dans ma mémoire
vous voyez le temps est long madame la
sénatrice
bien évidemment la question des services
publics dans les quartiers populaires
est au coeur de de notre réflexion la
mise en place des maisons France
services la mise en place des maisons de
la justice et du droit le complément qui
est fait dans l'éducation nationale dans
l'éducation prière dans la mise en place
des cités éducatives les dédoublement
des classes préparatoires des CE1 des
grandes sections et comme l'a annoncé le
président de la République dans le cadre
de quartier 2030 la scolarisation
précoce dans les écoles des quartiers
populaires le plus rapidement possible
et des moyens supplémentaires pour les
moyennes section est au cœur de nos
priorités l'action publique et vous le
savez madame la satrice elle agit dans
nos quartiers heureusement ou en serait
ton si depuis 40 ans la politique de la
ville n'avait pas fait son œuvre dans
ses quartiers populaires vous connaissez
le travail magnifique que fait l'Agence
nationale du renouvellement urbain
aujourd'hui sur les 453 quartiers qui
ont signé leur conventions en rue plus
de 450 ont commencé des chantiers 1300
chantiers ont été livrés parmi lesquels
plus de 100 écoles l'enruence et 500
écoles qui ont été livrées pour faire
place à cette priorité éducative dans
nos quartiers les vacances apprenantes
les quartiers d'été ont été mis en place
par le gouvernement précédent
aujourd'hui un maire qui s'en donne les
moyens et qui le souhaitent peut faire
partir beaucoup plus d'enfants dans des
colonies pour la moitié du prix qu'il le
faisait avant et je peux vous assurer
que ça marche pour y avoir
été utilisateur comme mère et pour avoir
été les visiter l'été dernier dans un
certain nombre de villes
ça marche quand les mers ça donne les
moyens madame la sénatrice à Sancy
et
là en l'occurrence
les mers les mers qui souhaitent
utiliser les dispositifs
je vous remercie
la parole est au président Roger
caoutchi pour le groupe les républicains
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre donc
la République comme la démocratie sont
des régimes fragiles
nous avons ici au Parlement voté des
textes souvent votre demande sur la
sécurité sur la justice vous préparez
des textes sur l'immigration à
l'intégration est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment avec tout ce qui se passe en
ce moment que ces textes suffisent pour
conforter la démocratie et la République
en France
[Musique]
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur
Darmanin
merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les seins le
ministrehaucci
je crois que comme la Ligue la première
ministre dans la réponse à Bruno
Retailleau il faut essayer de comprendre
ce qui s'est passé ces derniers jours
heureux ceux qui auraient des
explications simples
4000 appellations
âge moyen à 17 ans
un tiers de mineur
moins de 10% de personnes de nationalité
non françaises
et 60% monsieur ministre 60% de
personnes inconnues des services de
police même pas un fait même pas un
usage suppléant ou refus d'obtempérer le
contraire de la délinquance habituelle
sur les 500 villes
politique de la ville
plus de 150 n'ont pas connu des choux
fourrés
et puis il y a une centaine de villes
qui n'ont pas de quartier politique de
la ville et qui ont connu des
échauffourés
donc je crois monsieur le ministre
qu'avant de répondre totalement votre
question si j'évite la politique
politicienne et si je me dis qu'ensemble
on doit travailler pour le bien de la
République pour le bien de notre nation
je crois qu'il faut savoir se poser
quelques temps après avoir établi
totalement droit public depuis deux
jours les choses sont rétablies j'en
remercie les policiers les gendarmes les
magistrats les élus bien sûr tous ceux
qui contribuent mais que
il faut réfléchir parce que je crois que
dans une belle revue que j'avais lorsque
j'étais adhérent de la même famille
politique que vous il était écrit que
dans les victoires d'Alexandre on y
trouve toujours Aristote
[Musique]
alors
Aristote et le président caoutchi
presque arrivé mais Aristote n'est pas
Platon donc
je vais peut-être pas reprendre
là-dessus chez le ministre
je ne veux pas évoquer tous les sujets
de fond
l'échec de l'école pour des raisons
multiples échec de la politique
d'intégration à laquelle je suis très
attaché pour là aussi des raisons
multiples on aura l'occasion d'y revenir
mais je le dis très tranquillement avec
l'expérience de mon département bien sûr
mais aussi de tout le pays lorsque ça va
mal ou lorsqu'il y a crise il y a en
réalité de piliers de jambes pour
l'autorité de l'État et l'établissement
de la République c'est le Tricolore des
écharpes des élus locaux et le bleu de
nos forces de l'ordre gendarme policiers
police nationale sapeurs-pompiers ce que
nous vous demandons est-ce que nous
demandons à la première ministre ce
n'est pas de faire des miracles parce
que quand on dit il faut analyser les
raisons de fond oui enfin on les cite
beaucoup depuis 10-15 ans 20 ans
mais ce que nous demandons à la première
ministre à tout le gouvernement c'est de
dire que l'on va restituer aux mers la
politique locale c'est de dire que l'on
va réciter au maire la politique du
logement de l'urbanisme c'est de dire
que l'on a confiance dans nos forces de
l'ordre et ne pas avoir un discours
alternatif ou du en même temps vous
devez incarner l'état l'autorité de
l'État parce que sinon il n'y aura plus
de République
merci
la parole est à madame la Présidente
Laurent se Rossignol pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicains
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
partager avec les collègues ici présents
les membres du gouvernement le malaise
que m'inspire le débat public depuis
quelques jours il y a une semaine un
jeune garçon était tué par un policier
dans l'exercice des fonctions policiers
mis ensuite en examen pour homme ici
volontaire et aujourd'hui le procès
qu'instruise certains politiques et les
médias c'est celui des quartiers
prioritaires et des parents qui vivent
nous assistons à une véritable
manipulation fondée sur une part de
mensonge et beaucoup d'ignorance
j'espère non les quartiers prioritaires
ne sont pas inondés de subventions
publiques payées par des bons Français
méritants 6100 euros
euros par habitant par an dans les
quartiers prioritaires 6800 dans les
autres quartiers dans ces quartiers dans
certains immeubles 40% de mermonaux
parental qui enchaîne deux ou trois
boulots par jour qui gardent les enfants
des autres les nôtres souvent et qui ne
peuvent pas faire garder les eaux les
leurs des pères évaporées vous voulez
les poursuivre je suis d'accord avec
vous poursuivons-les utilisons ce qui
existe poursuivons-les pour abandon de
famille par exemple et dans les familles
où les personnes présents vous vous
intéressez à la violence des enfants
intéressons nous aussi à la violence que
ces enfants ont subi chez eux avec leur
mère et leur père alors madame la
Première ministre aujourd'hui au lieu de
laisser accuser les mers je vous propose
de les aider à survivre à vivre que nous
soutenions leurs associations que nous
les écoutions que nous les émancipions
du clientélisme municipal aussi mise en
sur les mers pour remettre les quartiers
d'aplomb ce serait probablement notre
meilleur investissement
on vous répondre la parole et monsieur
le garde des sceaux ministre de la
justice
merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs madame
la sénatrice rossignol
je pense qu'on ne veut pas poursuivre
les parents
c'est une caricature que dire cela ainsi
j'ai d'ailleurs dit moi-même que n'était
pas question à mon avis de supprimer des
allocations je pense en particulier je
pense en particulier aux femmes qui
travaillent qui sont seuls qui élèvent
leur famille
qui le font avec beaucoup de dignité
dans la difficulté je pense aussi à des
parents qui pourraient faire un certain
nombre de choses vis-à-vis de leurs
enfants en particulier assuré l'autorité
parentale et qui ne le font pas vous
voyez dans ces nuits courtes que nous
avons eu les uns et les autres émaillés
de mauvaises nouvelles et de vidéos il y
a une vidéo qui m'a plu c'est celle du
père qui va récupérer son gamin par le
callback et qui les iront à la maison
parce qu'il y a 11 ans traîne pas dans
les rues je me rappelais d'ailleurs que
nous avons tous nos souvenirs enfin pour
ceux qui se sont mariés des dispositions
de l'articles 212 du Code civil les
époux se doivent mutuellement fidélité
ce courrier assistance on oublie le
reste les parents ont une obligation
morale ça n'est pas plus compliqué que
ça à l'égard de leurs enfants oui et
ceux qui peuvent et qui ne le font pas
méritent d'être sanctionnés puis il y a
une responsabilité civile qui est très
simple c'est quand les enfants cassent
bah c'est les parents qui payent ça
existe depuis toujours et il faut le
rappeler enfin il y a une autre
responsabilité pénale qui consiste que
l'enfant est convoqué pour les parents
de l'accompagner devant la justice et
s'il ne le fait pas il encore une amende
qui est une amende importante j'ai
rappelé ça j'ai demandé au procureur de
le mettre en oeuvre je viens à
l'attention des parents de rédiger un
flyer voilà c'est pas plus compliqué que
ça qui explique en terme simple quels
sont les obligations pour les parents
madame la sénatrice qu'il aurait oublié
madame la Présidente
[Applaudissements]
merci Monsieur garde des sceaux je
prends acte du fait que pour vous la loi
suffit aujourd'hui pour protéger les
enfants et poursuivre les parents vous
savez mes chers collègues j'observe
depuis quelques années le monde
politique les hommes les femmes y
compris dans leur intimité et leur
difficulté de parents laissez-moi finir
il y a aussi chez nous des enfants
arrêtés placés en garde à vue mis en
examen et condamné nos enfants de son 10
meilleurs ni pire que ceux des autres
pour autant je vous invite à regarder
les autres parents avec un peu plus
d'empathie de bienveillance ils font
comme vous comme nous comme ils peuvent
au mieux
bon la parole est très collègues Arnaud
Bazin pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le président madame la
Première ministre mes chers collègues la
France entière a appris avec effroi la
tentative d'assassinat à l'encontre de
la famille de Monsieur le Maire de
L'Haÿ-les-Roses Vincent jambes les
Français savent peut-être moins que
Stéphanie vonneux madame le Maire de
Pontoise n'a réchappé d'un traquenard
que d'extrême justesse grâce à son
sang-froid et à la solidité de son
véhicule tire de mortier dans
l'habitacle jette projectile tentative
de la capturer bilan un tympe en détruit
des brûlures à la jambe et l'inévitable
choc psychologique même si elle était
même si elle y fait face avec beaucoup
de courage la France ne sait pas en
revanche que 24 heures après l'incendie
de ma mairie de coeur à Persan le
premier adjoint déjà menacé par les
flammes dans le bâtiment la veille a été
réveillé à son domicile par des coups
dans ses volets au cri de on est là on
est là
et je demande pardon à tous les autres
élus qui en ont subi autant de ne
pouvoir tous les citer ici mais je sais
que sur tous ces bandes nous pensons
tous à eux le maire représentant de sa
population et de l'État et maintenant
partout menacée déjà depuis des années
le moindre refus du maire dont le
moindre village pouvait déboucher sur
des cris des insultes démonaces et même
des agressions physiques le maire n'est
plus protégé par Laura d'autorité de sa
fonction parce qu'il représente l'État
dont trop de nos compatriotes récuse
maintenant l'autorité
l'enfant-roi est devenu un adulte tyran
alors madame la Première ministre
au-delà des quelques mesures que vous
avez déjà en magasin protection
juridique physique statut des élus
et vous faire pour rétablir à tout
moment et en tout lieu l'autorité de
l'État et donc celle des mères seul vrai
garante de leur sécurité au moment où la
population a tant besoin d'eux
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre délégué en charge des
collectivités territoriales
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Bazin les violences de ces
derniers jours n'ont pas manqué
d'exposer à nouveau nos élus beaucoup de
nos élus locaux beaucoup de nos mères je
veux souligner ici le courage qui a été
le leur pour défendre leur commune pour
défendre leur ville je veux rendre ici
hommage à celles et ceux qui ont été
agressés très souvent violemment par les
émeutiers j'ai notamment une pensée pour
Monsieur le Maire de L'Haÿ-les-Roses
Vincent Jean Brun ou de la mère de
Pontoise Stéphanie van le houx Boris
Ravignan son épouse bien sûr
à Vincent Jean Brun et en fait ces
agressions sont tout simplement
ignobles nous n'avons pas manqué de
mesurer aux côtés de madame la Première
ministre leur gravité la première façon
d'assurer la sécurité des élus dans
cette crise a été de déployer 45000
policiers nationaux et gendarmes pour
amener l'ordre les hommages que les élus
leur ont rendu ces derniers jours en
témoignent je veux saluer aussi le
courage de nos la sécurité intérieure de
nos pompiers de nos forces de secours et
de nos policiers municipaux nous avons
voulu répondre aussi à ces violences du
quotidien dès le 17 mai au moment de la
démission de Yannick Morin nous avons
protégé nos élus c'est pas moins depuis
deux mois de 3400 gendarmes référents
violences faites aux élus qui vont à la
rencontre de nos élus locaux qui vont
prendre en compte et couper évaluer
protéger et enquêter 1800 élus se sont
nouvellement inscrits depuis deux mois
sur le dispositif alarme dont je vous
parlais pas moins de trois plateformes
ont été déjà des référencé face à des
cyber violences cette plateforme
phareuse dont je vous citer le mérite il
y a quelques semaines il circulaire du
ministre de l'intérieur du garde des
sceaux et de moi-même est venu rappeler
au préfet au procureur que cette cause
est une priorité absolue et qu'elle
appelle une action résolue de leur part
nous voulons aller plus loin madame la
Première ministre a annoncé un plan
national de pré vention et de lutte
contre les violences qui s'inspirent de
vos travaux et que je vous présenterai
vendredi dans trois jours je vous
remercie j'ai besoin vous avez quelques
secondes
j'espérais comme Roger caoutchi vous me
répondriez décentralisation pouvoir des
communes pouvoir des mers je suis un peu
déçu mais j'attire votre attention sur
le fait que ce samedi nous risquons de
connaître le même désastre madame panot
vient d'appeler la terre entière à
manifestation entre persan et Beaumont à
l'occasion de l'anniversaire du décès de
Monsieur Adama Traoré je vous engage à
réfléchir à interdire cette
manifestation
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Gérard
pour Adja pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
madame la Première ministre lors de sa
prochaine visite annoncée en
Nouvelle-Calédonie fin juillet le
président de la République pour avoir
par lui-même comment agrandir le
cocotier qu'il avait planté à OVA avec
Ginette une petite fille au Canac de
l'île le 4 mai 2018 dénommé l'arbre de
l'avenir
le gouvernement s'est employé à faire
pousser cet arbre à la de l'avenir sous
votre autorité et celle du ministre de
l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer vous avez
tracé le cadre celui d'un accord global
et ambitieux la perspective la poursuite
de l'émancipation du pays y compris en
ce qui concerne certaines compétences
régaliennes les fondements les
fondamentaux
un peuple calaison qui pense à racine
dans une citoyenneté calédonienne
irréversible une Nouvelle-Calédonie une
et indivisible ce qui inclut toute
partition du pays
de rassemblement ou de projet au lieu de
référendum binaire comme je le défendais
déjà devant notre assemblée le 4 mai
2021 madame la Première ministre je suis
Canac calédonien et français je crois
plus que jamais au dessin commun entre
la France et la Nouvelle-Calédonie en
dessin commun nourri par une histoire
une langue une école et des valeurs mais
aussi par une souveraineté partagée
c'est pourquoi le prochain accord devra
nous conduire à fusionner ce qui nous a
toujours opposé jusqu'à lors la
souveraineté et la République madame la
Première ministre confirmez vous à notre
hôte assemblée que vous êtes prêtes à
vous inscrire dans cette perspective
dans le respect du résultat des trois
référendums pour que vive le peuple
calédonien
vivent la Nouvelle-Calédonie et vive la
france merci
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la Première ministre
[Applaudissements]
merci Monsieur Président Mesdames et
Messieurs dessinateurs monsieur le
sénateur
Gérard poadja les accords de Matignon en
1988 on manifesté la volonté des
Calédoniens de mettre fin au cycle des
violences
10 ans plus tard l'accord de Nouméa a
marqué une nouvelle étape renforçant la
prise en compte de l'identité Canac en
fondant de nouvelles institutions en
organisant le transfert des compétences
et en définissant le calendrier du
processus d'exercice du droit à
l'autodétermination
dans le respect des engagements pris en
1998 et sous l'autorité du Président de
la République les trois consultations
référendaires prévues par l'accord de
Nouméa ont été organisés en
2018-2020 et 2021 à trois reprises les
Calédoniens ont fait la même réponse et
au soir de la troisième consultation le
12 décembre 2021 le président de la
République a priacte de la volonté de la
majorité des Calédoniens de rester dans
la République et dans la nation
française
comme vous le savez mon gouvernement est
pleinement mobilisé pour accompagner les
discussions sur l'avenir de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie au sein de la
République et dans les dans le respect
des acquis de l'Accord de Nouméa le
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
Gérald Darmanin a confirmé dans un
récent courrier adressé ou partenaire
politique que les transferts de
compétences réalisées depuis 1998 tout
comme le principe d'une citoyenneté
calédonienne n'avait pas vocation à être
remise en cause pour autant les
conditions d'accès à cette citoyenneté
font d'ores et déjà l'objet d'échanges
avec l'ensemble des partenaires
politiques monsieur le sénateur je vous
confirme que le prochain accord
respectera la volonté exprimée par la
majorité des Calédoniens je vous
confirme que le prochain accord ne
remettra pas en cause le principe du
partage de souveraineté qui est
mentionné dans le préambule de l'Accord
de Nouméa et je forme le vœu que le
prochain accord ne soit pas que
juridique et institutionnel mais
poursuivent l'ambition d'un destin
commun calédonien je suis prête à
inviter l'ensemble des partenaires à la
fin du mois d'août pour un cycle de
réunions Trilatérale qui doit nous
permettre de conclure l'accord que les
Calédoniens attendent c'est bien
évidemment en lien avec Gérald Darmanin
et son équipe Jean-François carrerco et
Sonia bac S que nous préparons cette
rencontre je vous remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Muriel jourdat pour le groupe les
républicains
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le garde des sceaux
monsieur le ministre il y a quelques
semaines vous adressez au magistrat une
circulaire qui faisait état de la
conduite à tenir lorsque des infractions
étaient commises au cours de
manifestations
immédiatement le Syndicat de la
magistrature qui est plus connu du grand
public depuis une dizaine d'années grâce
aux tristement célèbre mur des cons le
Syndicat de la magistrature adressait
une contre circulaire
qui expliquait en substance comment ne
pas appliquer vos consignes plus
récemment suite aux événements qui ont
animé toute cette séance le Syndicat de
la magistrature publie est un communiqué
intitulé mort de Naël ce n'est pas à la
justice d'état de une révolte le
Syndicat de la magistrature y expliquait
dans une sorte de diatribe de quelle
façon il s'opposait au gouvernement il
s'opposait au syndicat policier et
évoquait des violences policières
je souhaiterais rappeler un principe qui
excitent la liberté syndicale et forte
dans sa liberté d'expression elle
s'arrête là où le statut du magistrat
arrête c'est-à-dire à l'impossibilité de
faire de la politique comment
comptez-vous monsieur le garde des
sceaux rappelez ce principe et le faire
appliquer
merci
pour vous répondre la parole est au
garde les Champs-Élysées de la justice
monsieur Dupont-Moretti merci madame la
sénatrice de me poser cette question
d'abord je voudrais vous dire sans
emballage et de façon très claire que je
partage vos inquiétudes totalement
le mur des cons il comporte la
photographie de Monsieur escar fight qui
a un tort c'est d'avoir vu sa fille se
faire assassiner
durant les deux tours de l'élection
présidentielle le Syndicat de la
magistrature a dit que c'était un
deuxième tour de cauchemar
et puis le Syndicat de la magistrature
souhaite choisir son ministre
et le Syndicat de la magistrature
souhaite même qu'il n'y ait plus de
ministère de la Justice
j'aurais pu rappeler tout ça mais je ne
le ferai pas mais
je vais en réalité
m'arrêter sur cette fausse circulaire
Canada Dry car elle ressemble à une
circulaire que prend le garde des sceaux
oui elle incite même les magistrats
d'ailleurs à violer les textes de loi
donc j'y vois une forme d'humour en ce
qui me concerne voyez-vous madame la
sénatrice et je ne veux pas aller plus
loin moi je vais vous dire je me bats au
quotidien pas pour le Syndicat de la
magistrature mais pour les magistrats et
pour améliorer leurs conditions et je
vous remercie le Sénat d'avoir voté le
texte que j'ai présenté ici et puis
peut-être une toute dernière chose
je suis le seul à pouvoir prendre une
circulaire de politique pénale parce que
je suis le garde des sceaux et parce que
démocratiquement je vous dois des
comptes ce qui n'est pas le cas du
Syndicat de la magistrature
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le garde des sceaux que notre
indignation commune doit sortir de cette
hémicycle et aller au-delà je pense que
dans les temps troublés que nous
connaissons il faut effectivement que
chacun dans son rôle chaque institution
qui en charge de l'État de droit le
rappel et joue son rôle dans cet état de
droit le pilier de l'État de droit qu'il
a justice ne peut pas critiquer
impunément à notre pilier que sont les
forces de l'ordre l'autorité judiciaire
ne peut pas se transformer en pouvoir
politique et je crois que nous
ramènerons pas l'ordre dans le pays si
nous n'avons pas d'ordre dans nos
institutions
[Applaudissements]
merci ma chère collègue
la parole est à notre collègue Annie le
héros pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
monsieur le ministre de la santé et de
la prévention la nuit dernière j'ai eu
15 patients qui ont fait plus de 60 km
pour venir aux urgences de Rennes chaque
matin on compte 20 à 40 patients qui ont
passé la nuit sur des brancards avec un
risque de surmortalité de 50% faute de
lit avale disponible la solution serait
de laisser les patients attendre dans
les ambulances plus sécurisées mais
alors qui va aller chercher les patients
les transports sanitaires sont aussi
saturés paroles d'urgentiste à Carrel et
services d'urgence sont fermés en
juillet-août alors que la vieille
charrue accueilleront 280 000
festivaliers l'hôpital le plus proche
est à 90 km et 1h15 de route la
maternité de Guingamp n'accueille plus
les femmes pour accoucher suspension
reconduites 4 mois faute de personnel
épuisées d'avoir tenu à bout de bois ce
service on a l'impression d'être
abandonné en tentant dans les cortèges
de manifestants vous suspendez les
activités des petits hôpitaux elle se
reporte sur les la méthode de référence
sur les CHU eux-mêmes exemples à Pontivy
avranges Les Sables-d'Olonne dans tous
les centres hospitaliers de France ce
sont des cris d'alarme des médecins en
grève hier les ARS rassurent appellent
aux soignants éducation des patients
régulation appelée le 15 avant de vous
déplacer mais au 15 les équipes n'en
peuvent plus pas assez nombreux les
urgentistes quittent l'hôpital pour des
conditions de travail moins
contraignantes la médecine de ville ne
va pas mieux et les cabinets de
consultation remplacent les cabines de
consultation remplacent les médecins de
proximité monsieur le ministre la
situation s'aggrave elle n’inquiète plus
nos concitoyens ni les élus locaux elle
les angoisses quelle réponse concrète à
cette crise aiguë de l'hôpital public et
des urgences dès cet été soit
aujourd'hui
pour vous répondre la parole de cas au
ministre de la Santé de la prévention
monsieur le ministre merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs et
Center madame la sénatrice le héros oui
nous manquons professionnels de santé le
diagnostic n'est malheureusement pas
nouveau et oui ce gouvernement agit en
formant plus de médecins mais il va
falloir attendre 10 ans en formant
encore plus d'infirmiers plus 6000 plus
d'aide-soignant plus 3000 et les
fermetures qui sont souvent pas pour les
services d'urgence simplement des accès
régulés que vous évoquez ne sont pas du
fait d'une décision qui serait
économique mais simplement parce que
nous manquons de professionnels de santé
donc la solution viendra en redonnant
plus de temps à ses professionnels ce
que nous avons commencé à faire et en en
formant plus que nous faisons également
concernant les urgences et vous le savez
c'est une priorité forte encore
renforcée pour cet été vous avez évoqué
un certain nombre de solutions qui sont
mises en place mais ce sont des
solutions mise en place déjà l'été
dernier et qui fonctionne puisque l'été
dernier nous avons diminué de 5% la fré
de nos services d'urgence ce qui n'avait
pas été le cas depuis plus de 20 ans
alors ces solutions elles sont autour de
trois axes un premier axe qui est
effectivement l'information de nos
concitoyens sur le bon usage du système
de santé et en particulier le bon usage
des urgences pour lequel avant de se
déplacer si votre médecin n'est pas
disponible oui il faut appeler le 15
parce qu'on vous trouvera la meilleure
solution adaptée en fonction du
territoire où vous êtes et dans ce cadre
là nous renforçons la régulation
médicale nous accélérons le déploiement
de ce service d'accès aux soins qui
intègre des médecins généralistes à la
régulation nous renforçons leur
rémunération nous avons grâce à ce qui a
été voté par le Parlement transformer
les assistants de régulation médicale en
professionnelle de santé permettant là
aussi de valoriser leur exercice et puis
il faut aussi des efflecteurs sur le
terrain c'est le cas en ville plus 15
euros pour les actes qui sont réalisés à
la demande de cette régulation c'est le
cas également au niveau des transports
sanitaires vous en avez parlé ou on
facilite le transport vers les médecins
généralistes et également en renforçant
les communautés professionnelles des pas
peur de santé à l'hôpital nous avons
pris en compte la pénibilité en
augmentant en doublant même l'indemnité
de nuit pour le personnel paramédical en
multipliant par 1,5 pour les médecins
nous travaillons également et nous avons
développé une logique territoriale que
ce soit pour les gardes en associant
public et privé mais également pour la
gestion des lignes dont vous parlez qui
ce matin à l'échelle du territoire et
puis un délai seulement à l'échelle d'un
établissement donc oui les solutions
sont mises en place et pour certaines
elle fonctionne au CD déjà et pour les
autres elle commence à montrer leur
efficacité je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
le ministre il y a urgence aux urgences
et vous ne répondez pas à cette urgence
l'accès aux soins pour
tous c'est parti de la promesse
républicaine on en est loin la
défaillance de la médecine de ville
conduit à l'engorgement des
urgences alors que les limaces en
avalent le système est embolisé où vont
exercer les médecins qui quittent
l'hôpital une remise à plat du service
public de santé s'impose et ce ne sont
pas vos propositions qui régleront le
problème
la parole est à notre collègue Michel
bonus pour le groupe les républicains
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues monsieur ma question s'adresse
à monsieur le ministre de l'économie et
des finances plus de 1000 commerces
pillés 250 bureaux de tabac détruit plus
d'un milliards d'euros de dégâts pour
les entreprises ces chiffres sont
édifiants ils auraient pu être encore
plus importants sur le travail de nos
forces de l'ordre que nous remercions
la mort d'un jeune de justifie pas les
vagues de violence de pillage auxquelles
nous avons assisté aucun commerce est à
l'abri je ne vous cache pas notre
inquiétude et je suis certain que la
partager
c'est certainement impactent durement
les commerçants des professionnels qui
ont quatre coins du pays vivent dans une
situation de tripes insécurité
insécurité matérielle d'abord elle est
en passant de retrouver un taco qui
travaille au petit matin alors qu'il se
battent depuis des années pour le
construire insécurité physique et
psychologique ensuite
pardon et c'est elle qui angoissée doit
faire face à des situations hors de
contrôle et bien sûr insécurité
économique car il n'est pas certain de
pouvoir compter sur la solidarité des
banques et des assurances en cas de
pillage cette triple sécurité des
commerçants le vivent plus lentement
trop longtemps
plus de 50 samedi de blocage dans le
centre-ville avec les gilets jaunes
trois mois de manifestation contre les
réformes de retraite et maintenant une
semaine des maths et tout cela
évidemment conjugué aux autres
difficultés inflation crise de l'énergie
et bien sûr la crise de covid et le
remboursement du PGE constitue un
vêtement supplémentaire victime
collatérale de ces événements ils sont
systématiquement parmi les premiers
empires vous ne pouvez pas fermer les
yeux sur la situation de cette France
qui travaille qui se bat qui crée et
maintient pour maintenir de l'emploi
elle mérite plutôt que plus que jamais
le soutien de l'État à qui ils
reviennent d'assurer sa fonction
régalienne première la sécurité
les annulations de charge au cas par cas
pour les seuls commerces les plus
touchés ce n'est pas suffisant ils sont
tout le touchés directement ou
indirectement et les ont besoin de
mesures fortes quelles mesures durable
envisagez-vous pour soutenir les
commerçants dans ces épreuves ce
ministre
pour vous répondre la parole est à
Madame Olivia Grégoire
qui est ministre délégué chargé des
petites et moyennes entreprises vous
avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Sénateur bonus
je tiens aussi
comme vous à remercier les forces de
l'ordre grâce auquel nos commerçants
même si vous l'avez dit plus d'un
millier d'entre eux a été touché
ont pu quand même pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux ré-ouvrir je voudrais dans
ces moments difficiles à avoir un mot
bien sûr de soutien ça va vous étonner
un petit mot d'espoir aussi
436 bar-tabac pour être précis ce n'est
pas 250
c'est bien plus 160 d'entre eux
aujourd'hui même sont ouverts et on
recommençait à travailler pas toujours
avec les vitrines nickel mais ils sont
déjà autre retournés au boulot vous
l'avez dit il faut je reprends vos mots
il faut ouvrir les yeux je tiens à vous
dire que Bruno Le Maire et moi-même
avons les yeux grands ouverts ça a été
le cas pendant le covid je pense que
d'ailleurs les commerçants le
reconnaissent l'État a été à leur côté
ça a été le cas et ça l'est encore pour
un certain nombre de difficultés sur les
factures d'électricité et c'est aussi le
cas depuis le début des émeuts dès
samedi nous avons réunis les assureurs
les banquiers dès lundi nous les avons
revu oui il y aura au cas par cas des
annulations de charge oui nous avons
mobilisé les assureurs c'est non pas 5
jours mais 30 jours que nos commerçants
auront pour reprendre un peu de souffle
faire leur déclaration j'en profite pour
vous dire deux réflexes vous avez été
touché porter plainte appelez votre
assureur nous avons des commerçants qui
pour certains sont sidérés je tiens
aussi à vous dire que j'ai un
pot.gouv.fr vous avez la liste de tous
les conseillers départementaux à la
sortie de crise qui dans chaque
préfecture accompagne nos commerçants
depuis des mois d'ailleurs pour le
problème de l'électricité ces
conseillers départementaux ont
aujourd'hui aussi un soutien
psychologique à la disposition de nos
commerçants on parle beaucoup
d'économies on parle beaucoup de
remboursement ce qu'on m'a dit sur le
terrain avant-hier hier c'est Madame
Grégoire et c'était pareil pour Bruno Le
Maire c'est un soutien psychologique
qu'on a besoin aussi parce qu'on est
sidéré donc sachez juste monsieur venu
qu'on l'intègre et que dans les
préfectures de France avec des
associations on va aussi les accompagner
moralement au-delà de la reconstruction
que ce soit les assureurs les banquiers
le soutien moral et psychologique ne
n'ayez pas de doute nous serons à leur
côté aujourd'hui et dans la
reconstruction qui est devant nous merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur bonus
vous avez quelques secondes
merci merci Madame la Ministre sachez
que on doit se préparer aux autres aux
autres événements malheureusement et si
ça devient un redondant et de subir
comme ça chaque fois c'est c'est plus
qu'un boissant et je crois que c'est une
prise de conscience collective et il
faut il faut tout se mobiliser c'est
trop dur ça devient trop compliqué merci
beaucoup merci
avant de donner la parole je souhaite
saluer notre collègue Bernard bonne qui
va prendre la parole et qui a décidé lui
et bien
de nous quitter le premier octobre et de
pas renouveler son mandat à la suite de
son action comme président du Conseil
général de la Loire je voudrais rappeler
ce qu'il a fait au sein de la commission
des affaires sociales notamment sur la
question du grand âge il a été le
rapporteur avec Michel meunier de la
mission d'information sur le contrôle
des EHPAD l'an dernier un vrai sujet de
société majeure que la place du grand
âge dans notre société je voulais le
remercier d'avoir éveillé nos
consciences sur ce sujet
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le Président de ma question
justement s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre des Solidarités et du grand âge
et cela fait des années monsieur le
ministre quand nous annonce une loi
grand âge séparait-il comme beaucoup
d'autres une priorité du gouvernement
depuis 2017
manifestement il n'y aura pas de grands
soir puisque le 4 avril dernier vous
avez annoncé je reprends vos termes que
cette réforme se ferait en plusieurs
briques soit j'aurais préféré pour ma
part parler d'une fusée à plusieurs
étages et ce qui m'inquiète c'est que la
fusée a bien du mal à décoller la pppl
bien vieillir examinée à l'Assemblée
nationale en avril dernier n'apporte pas
toutes les réponses attendues mais elle
a été enrichie de mesures concrètes
positives la poursuite de son examen est
alors du jour je m'en réjouis mais il
faudra attendre encore de longues
semaines avant qu'elle ne soit examinée
au Sénat pendant ce temps suite aux
travaux d'une fabrique du Bien vieillir
mais dans le cas du CNR vous deviez nous
annoncer début juin un plan d'action
détaillé qui ne relève pas de la loi
nous attendons toujours monsieur le
ministre et puis tout le monde sait le
nerf de la guerre c'est le financement
le troisième étage devront devrait être
donc être à l'examen du PLFSS à
l'automne car le rapport Libaud qui le
dit et qu'il affirme près de 10
milliards d'euros supplémentaires par an
seront nécessaires dès 2030 pour
financer la dépendance alors Monsieur le
Ministre quand donc allez-vous alimenter
le moteur de cette fusée et répandra
ainsi aux attentes de nos concitoyens et
des professionnels du secteur
pour vous répondre la parole
Jean-Christophe con mini des solidarités
de l'autonomie et des personnes
handicapées Vous AVEZ LA PAROLE Monsieur
Merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Bernard Bones alors
permettez-moi de profiter de votre
question pour à mon tour saluer le
travail remarquable et reconnu de tous
que vous avez effectué ici au Sénat tant
dans le secteur de la protection de
l'enfance que dans celui du grand âge
engagement que nous partageons
aujourd'hui alors vous m'interrogez
justement sur la question de la
politique du grand âge j'aurais un
regret de manifestement c'est de nos
discussions de ne pas avoir réussi à
vous convaincre que la politique résolue
déterminée du gouvernement était dépassé
très largement l'ambition et le champ
d'un grand projet d'un grand projet de
loi grand âge vous savez on agit avec
une double temporalité celle de
l'urgence et l'année dernière lorsque
j'ai été nommé ministre vous m'avez
présenté avec Michel meunier vos
conclusions sur la question du contrôle
des EHPAD et on a travaillé ensemble à
l'inscription d'un certain nombre de
mesures dans le cadre du projet loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
assurer la transparence la moralisation
du secteur ramenait de la confiance et
puis on a travaillé également sur des
mesures d'urgence pour soutenir un
secteur qui en grande difficulté
économique aujourd'hui on y travaille
avec les agences régionales de santé et
avec les départements au quotidien pour
faire en sorte qu'il y ait pas de
défaillance concernant la réforme du
grand âge je vous l'ai dit ce qui fera
foi c'est la feuille de route que je
vais présenter prochainement qui est
issu des conclusions du CNR du Conseil
national de la refondation dédiée au
Bien Vieillir qui a conclu le 4 avril et
qui visera à adapter notre société au
vieillissement à relever ce défi du
vieillissement de la société c'est une
feuille de route interministérielle
parce qu'elle concerne aussi les
transports elle concerne le logement et
concerne notre système de santé elle
concerne aussi les comportements
individuels dans ce que on pourra porter
en matière de prévention pour
assurer un vieillissement en bonne santé
on travaillera à la question de la
citoyenneté et du lien social bien
vieillir c'est vieillir aussi en lien ou
qu'on travaillera à la question de la
transformation évidemment de l'offre
médico-sociale tant en établissement que
à domicile et donc c'est tout ça que je
porterai dans cette feuille de route qui
se déclinera dans la proposition de loi
du Bien Vieillir pour ce qui relève de
la loi ou pour ce qui concerne les
financements dans le cadre de la loi de
finances et la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour l'année prochaine
tu es bonne
oui merci monsieur le ministre je
m'attendais bien à une réponse de ce
type mais quand même la loi grand âge
est importante et je ne doute pas de
votre volonté de faire aboutir cette loi
ainsi que son financement mais je crains
faire que le gouvernement auquel vous
appartenez ne soit pas aussi volontaire
et décidé persuadez monsieur le ministre
que nos aînés ont le droit de vieillir
dans la dignité nous le leur devons bien
merci
nous avons terminé avec les questions au
Gouvernement des prochaines questions au
Gouvernement relié le mercredi 12
juillet à 15h je vais suspendre la
séance elle sera reprise à 16h35 pour la
suite de l'examen du projet de loi
visant à sécuriser et réguler l'espace
numérique la séance est suspendue
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité du Sénat au gouvernement
avec une grande majorité de questions
posées par les sénateurs sur ces
violences urbaines qui ont éclaté dans
tout le pays ces derniers jours après la
mort du jeune tué par un policier et
maintenant place aux réactions à cette
séance de questions d'actualité
j'accueille Jérôme Durand bonjour vous
êtes sénateur socialiste de
Saône-et-Loire et vous avez interrogé
cet après-midi le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald de Darmanin notamment
sur les causes de ces violences urbaines
après la mort du jeune nail et pour vous
c'est la mauvaise relation entre ces
jeunes de quartier une partie de la
population et la police mais on a
l'impression que pour Charles Le
Darmanin c'est pas vraiment la cause oui
il a pas répondu la question entre
clairement il fallait saluer l'action
des forces de l'ordre pour ramener le
calme nous l'avons fait nous avons
appelé au calme nous avons appelé à
l'apaisement il est temps de se
retourner vers les causes profondes de
ce qui s'est passé et il y a quand même
un divorce entre une partie de la
population et la police et on ne peut
pas passer sous silence le sujet des
discriminations d'une population qui ne
se sent pas respecter de pratiques
policières qui parfois peuvent poser
problème et c'est des questions qu'on a
posées pendant la lothmique on a posé
pendant sécurité globale et on
interpelle sans cesse le ministre sur ce
sujet là donc il faut y revenir c'est le
question c'est la question aussi des
refus d'obtempérer voilà tout ça est sur
la table et maintenant il faut apporter
les réponses donc pour vous il y aura
une réforme de la police à apporter à
long terme après si on vient de se
passer nous n'avons pas mégoté notre
soutien à la locmi pour que la police et
les moyens pour porter de nouveaux
projets des questions technologiques des
questions de moyens mais il faut
effectivement se poser des questions sur
le fonctionnement et notamment ce sujet
rapporte alors que 16h30 dans quelques
minutes il y aura une audition du
ministre Gérald de Darmanin de ministre
de l'Intérieur devant les sénateurs
merci beaucoup pour votre réaction merci
merci beaucoup Alexandre d'ailleurs
Jérôme dure à préciser qu'il allait
réinterroger le ministre dans moins
d'une dizaine de minutes sur ce sujet
mais en attendant et bien on continue
les réactions sales des conférences vous
êtes avec le président du groupe les
républicains Bruno Retailleau oui Bruno
vous avez demandé à la première ministre
une politique de courage pour répondre à
plus ou moins moyen terme à cette
situation des violences urbaines dans
les quartiers est-ce que avoir
finalement une réponse trop ferme ça ne
va pas cela ne va pas au final et bien
braquer un peu plus les jeunes de ces
quartiers ah non mais les violences il
faut pas les prendre comme un chantage
parce que si à chaque violence la
République doit se coucher ça sera dans
sauvagement général et on arrivera au
terme de cette envie d'un sauvagement à
la guerre civile donc ce que j'ai voulu
dire c'est que trop souvent beaucoup de
gouvernements n'ont pas traité les
causes les vraies raisons les causes
racines mais ils ont traité les
conséquences des causes en déversant une
pluie de milliards sur ces quartiers
difficiles et pour moi les causes je les
ai rappelé c'est l'échec scolaire qui
met en échec beaucoup de jeunes c'est
aussi la faillite de l'autorité
parentale c'est le chaos migratoire et
c'est aussi une réponse pénale qui
inadaptée aujourd'hui à des adolescents
violents justement vous parlez de Kao
migratoire vous faites un lien entre
l'immigration et ses violences urbaines
et vous avez évoqué ce matin sur France
Info c'est jeune qui sont français mais
qui connaissent une régression vers
leurs origines ethniques alors une
partie de la gauche dénonce je cite des
propos racistes ce que vous voulez
regrettez mais je ne regrette rien du
tout je n'enlève rien du tout simplement
ce que j'ai dit c'est que dans ces
quartiers on voit bien que des gamins ou
des aides de l'essence qui sont issus de
de l'immigration
pour suivre un chemin inverse à celui
qu'on attend deux c'est à dire intégrer
complètement le modèle républicain je me
souviens très bien c'était en 2001 je
sais pas si vous aimez le foot c'était
tiré Henri vous souvenez le fameux match
entre France Algérie la marseillaise qui
avait été construit et Thierry Henry a
vu cette phrase nous avons joué à
l'extérieur c'est exactement ce que je
veux caractériser j'ai ajouté ce matin
si vous écoutez bien mon interview qui a
sans doute une part de responsabilité
parce que nous ne donnons pas
suffisamment à aimer la France à ces
jeunes générations parce qu'on a
présenté la France pas nous mais
d'autres comme un contre-exemple comme
un contre Madère si vous leur dites que
la France et les nécessairement coupable
de tout du pire des crimes comment
voulez-vous que ces jeunes là puis
centrer dans ce projet républicain c'est
ça que j'ai voulu dire et je maintiens
chacun de mes termes donc on peut
finalement on a une part de
responsabilité l'état une part de
responsabilité dans ce malaise de ces
jeunes ce que je dis c'est pas voyez
vous cherchez à me faire dire qu'il
faudrait culpabiliser la France mais à
force de culpabiliser la France on a
présenté la France comme un pays qui
n'était pas aimable quand on ne donnait
pas à aimer donc arrêtons la repentance
parce que cette repentance perpétuelle
je vais vous dire c'est une barrière qui
empêche ces jeunes là de s'assimiler
complètement à notre modèle républicain
qui oublient les origines qui oublient
les croyances c'est le citoyen universel
plutôt que l'individu avec ses
particularités c'est ce que j'ai voulu
dire ce matin sur l'autorité parentale
est-ce que sanctionner financièrement
notamment des maires de famille qui sont
isolées peut-être pour certaines démunis
est-ce que ça ne va pas encore les
accablés écoutez les chaussons claires
en France nous sommes une république en
face des droits il y a des devoirs la
location familiale ou des prestations
sociales ce sont des droits et en face
il y a des devoirs on perçoit une
allocation familiale parce que on rend
un service à la société on a des enfants
ayant les élèves et on les éduque si on
a des familles défaillantes et bien on
doit pouvoir suspendre les allocations
familiales c'est comme ça que ça marche
les droites et les devoirs donc pour
vous il y a pas de réponse sociale à ce
malaise des banlieues il peut y avoir
des réponses sociales aussi mais si vous
ne craquez pas les causes racines leur
établissement de l'autorité à la fois
parentale la transmission des savoirs
fondamentaux avec l'école le chaos
migratoire qui nous empêche à force de
flux trop important de bien assimiler
ces populations et bien avec une réponse
pénale très très ferme vous n'y
parviendrez pas c'est ce que l'on fait
on a déversé des milliards et des
milliards 10 milliards plus dix
milliards par an et alors où on en est
donc on voit bien que le problème est la
solution ça n'est pas toujours plus de
dépenses publiques merci beaucoup pour
nos Retailleau pour votre réaction merci
merci beaucoup Alexandre et puis vous
allez enchaîner les réactions en cette
salle des conférences avant que l'on
rejoigne la commission des lois où va
être auditionnée Gérald Darmanin
précisément sur ces émeutes et tout de
suite à votre micro le ministre de
l'éducation nationale papaye que l'on
n'a pas entendu s'exprimer sur ce sujet
des émeutes de cette jeunesse après la
mort de Naël la semaine dernière et on
l'entend à présent à votre micro bonjour
papa Ndiaye bonjour on va parler de la
question de l'école et du lien avec ces
violences urbaine mais d'abord une
réaction sur ce que vient de dire le
président du groupe les républicain au
Sénat Bruno Retailleau et sur ce lien
qu'il fait entre les origines ethniques
des jeunes de ces quartiers qui ont
participé aux violences est-ce que selon
vous il y a un lien entre immigration et
ses émeutes des banlieues lorsqu'on le
fait une sociologie et une géographie
des événements qui sont survenus ces
derniers jours on voit que des villes
sans quartiers prioritaires sont
concernés que des petites villes ont été
concernées qui n'ont rien à voir avec
des phénomènes migratoires bref qu'il y
a une diversité au fond dans les
caractéristiques sociales et
géographiques des émeutes qui interdit
de tracer des liens trop facile et entre
nous soit dit avec quand même des
relents assez gênants entre immigration
et ou technicité pour reprendre ce terme
et puis le comportement est métier c'est
tout à fait inexact des relances gênants
racistes diriez-vous écoutez c'est une
manière de pointer du doigt une partie
de la jeunesse la justice bien entendu
doit punir celles et ceux qui se sont
mal comportés quel que soit leurs
origines quel que soit leur prénom c'est
la République ce sont les principes
républicains qui sont en jeu et elle
s'appliquent à toutes et à tous alors
sur les écoles ont été dégradés attaqué
dans ces violences urbaines est-ce que
certaines écoles ne pourront pas rouvrir
en septembre à la rentrée il est clair
que des écoles entièrement détruites
comme les écoles de la verrière par
exemple dans les Yvelines ne pourront
pas rouvrir à la rentrée la
reconstruction va prendre du temps bien
entendu ce qu'on a un chiffre nous avons
une petite dizaine d'écoles dont nous
pensons qu'elles ne pourront pas rouvrir
à la rentrée il y a des expertises bien
entendu à réaliser pour une soixantaine
d'autres il y a des travaux à faire ces
travaux vont être réalisés pendant l'été
mais quoi qu'il arrive tous les enfants
seront scolarisés à partir du 4
septembre soit dans leur établissement
ou leur école soit dans une autre école
ou dans un autre établissement sur la
reconstruction l'État sera aux côtés des
communes pour réhabiliter ces écoles la
première ministre a dit que l'État
serait en effet aux côtés des
collectivité un certain nombre de
solutions seront trouvées parce que la
priorité bien entendu c'est les
réparations c'est la reconstruction de
manière à retrouver aussi rapidement
possible des écoles en bon état ou des
écoles malheureusement
reconstruite puisque c'est le cas d'un
certain nombre d'entre elles combien ça
coûterait là est-ce que le montant
évalué non il y a des expertises
techniques à faire il y a des travaux à
faire à mener par un certain nombre
d'ingénieurs et d'architectes nous
n'avons pas d'évaluation pour l'instant
alors il y a une analyse de fond des
causes de ces violences urbaines qui va
être faites ça va prendre du temps mais
d'abord est-ce que vous pouvez dire que
bien il y a aussi une faillite de
l'école qui explique ces violences de
ces jeunes de 12-13 ans qui se
retrouvaient bien la nuit à voilà à
jeter des cocktails Molotov sur les
policiers par exemple
je ne parle pas de et je ne parlerai
certainement pas de faillite de l'école
je veux rendre hommage de ce point de
vue
enseignants aux équipes éducatives qui
sont mobilisées tous les jours pour
travailler dans les écoles et les
établissements aux côtés de nos élèves
pour leur réussite dans des conditions
qui ne sont pas toujours simples de son
côté l'état mobilise des moyens
l'éducation prioritaire c'est 2,3
milliards aujourd'hui c'était 1,6
milliards en 2017 ils nous enregistrons
des résultats qui sont des résultats qui
ne sont pas mauvais du point de vue des
enquêtes que nous faisons du point de
vue des évaluations du niveau en 6e par
exemple en français et en mathématiques
nous progressons donc il n'y a pas
faillite de l'école mais il y a bien
entendu beaucoup de travail à faire
notamment du point de vue de la
formation professionnelle le taux de
chômage a baissé ces dernières années
mais il est encore trop élevé il est
environ il est d'environ 18% ces trois
fois plus que la moyenne nationale nous
avons des enjeux de formation nous avons
de ce point de vue là
pénal qui peut se traduire d'ailleurs
par des condamnations et par des amendes
et donc de ce point de vue là il y a
évidemment il peut y avoir des enjeux
financiers mais j'insiste sur le fait
qu'il n'est pas question de parler de
retrait d'allocation j'ai même entendu
parler
d'expulser des familles de logements
sociaux comme si faire des SDF ça allait
améliorer la situation ajouter la misère
la misère ça ne résout rien merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre pour votre
réaction au micro de Public Sénat merci
beaucoup Alexandre un papedia qui ferme
d'opposition que fait la droite
sénatoriale à la suite et bien de ces
émeutes qui ont été largement le sujet
de cette séance de questions au
gouvernement et on va d'ailleurs aller
voir et bien à présent Audrey vuettaz
juste pour dire un mot sur les échanges
qui ont marqué cette séance de questions
au Gouvernement oui ces questions au
gouvernement qui ont permis d'en
apprendre plus sur le profil des
émeutiers on savait déjà qu'ils étaient
très jeunes avec une moyenne d'âge de 17
ans pour les interpeller on a appris
aussi qu'ils étaient pour la majorité
inconnue des services de police c'est
Gérald de Darmanin qui a donné cette
information
merci merci beaucoup Audrey d'ailleurs
on voit et bien le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin qui se
trouve à côté du président de la
commission des lois c'est François Noël
buffet pour une audition qui va être
consacrée à ce sujet ce sujet des
émeutes qui ont enflammé les banlieues
françaises notez que Gérald Darmanin a
été interrogé alors de cette séance de
questions au gouvernement notamment par
Jérôme Durand et que l'on a entendu tout
à l'heure sur les rapports et bien entre
la police et la population que et bien
le sénateur socialiste devrait et bien à
nouveau interroger le ministre de
l'Intérieur sur ce sujet tout à l'heure
vous allez pouvoir suivre cette audition
en direct dans son intégralité Gérald
Darmanin qui a parlé et bien du
caractère assez inédit de des émeutes
qui sont très différentes à inexpliquées
de précédentes par exemple celle de 2005
et tout de suite on va prendre la
direction de cette audition c'est le
président de la Commission des lois
Françoise buffet qui s'exprime site
internet du Sénat et que par ailleurs la
durée de notre réunion et de l'ordre
d'une heure une heure 10 le ministre
devant se rendre à une réunion pour 18h
se faire de ma part c'est le ministre
vous avez accepté de venir cet
après-midi devant notre commission pour
évoquer la situation que le pays vient
de vivre il y a maintenant plusieurs
jours pour ne pas dire plusieurs nuits
bien sûr que l'origine de l'événement
est un événement dramatique
mais en aucun cas cet événement
dramatique ne peut justifier les émeutes
qui ont eu ensuite et la violence
j'allais dire la déferlante de violence
qui s'est
envahit le pays en tous les cas un grand
nombre de villes de villages où l'avait
rappelé aux questions d'actualité
de toute nature y compris sur des
critères que nous n'avons pas l'habitude
d'avoir c'est la des villages paisibles
voir des communes paisibles les gens
connais quelques-unes qui ont été la
cible d'incendie d'automobile ou de
bâtiments ou des tirs de mortiers
les images de télévision
ont montré la violence avec laquelle
cette situation a été a eu lieu vous
avez mobilisé beaucoup de personnels de
police bien sûr
les pompiers ont été mobilisés les
magistrats cela a été rappelé ont été
aussi immobilisés pour apporter une
réponse pénale rapide
mais il n'empêche que sur le fond les
questions demeure aujourd'hui si la
situation est apaisée nous devons sans
doute vous en féliciter
il n'en demeure pas moins que on
s'interroge tous de savoir pour combien
de temps
et on s'interroge tous pour savoir quel
remède demain
ce que nous partageons comme constat et
c'est là-dessus que nous souhaiterions
vous entendre c'est qu'en réalité
mérit bibliothèque espace public
lieu communal au lieu d’état voire
tribunaux ont été attaqués incendiés y
compris la maison d'arrêt de Fresnes
en réalité on se rend compte aujourd'hui
que c'est la République
c'est l'autorité qui est attaquée d'une
façon générale
les événements d'hier au tribunal
judiciaire de Lyon à l'occasion de
l'audience qui devait juger les
personnes qui ont été arrêtées et
renvoyés devant le tribunal le fait que
cette audience ait été suspendue parce
que des militants
d'ultra gauche étaient présents on
perturbait l'audience en insultant
d'ailleurs la police dans un lieu de
justice
sont autant d'éléments qui nous
interrogent sur la suite des événements
sur les motivations réelles des voyous
délinquants au criminels
je ne parle même pas des agressions
portées à l'égard des élus bien sûr
les événements récents concernant le
maire de la commune de l'ay-les-roses
mais je rappelle quand même de Lyon pas
trop vite le maire de Saint-Brévin je
rappelle madame le Maire de plougresco
je rappelle beaucoup d'autres qui depuis
ce système manifesté pour dire qu'ils
étaient les victimes de violence
dans mon département amer à lui-même
était aussi
attaqué à son domicile
bref tout est dit la situation est
dramatique la réponse
policière et la remise en ordre est en
cours et vous l'avez menée et ne vous
soutenons la question de fond et de
savoir comment demain les choses
évolueront et comment nous réagirons aux
attaques contre la République mais non
cette situation nous voulons des
explications monsieur le ministre sur
qui a fait quoi comment comprendre les
choses et essayer de déterminer la
réalité des choses car nous sommes tous
bien convaincus ici que l'ensemble des
populations des quartiers appelés de
banlieue des quartiers difficiles sont
des gens qui ont envie de vivre
tranquille
qui ont envie d'éduquer leurs enfants
qui se sont inscrits évidemment dans la
République quels dans notre République
exactement et qui avec leurs moyens
essayent de évidemment vivre normalement
donc il est bien question de faire une
réflexion de fonds de ne pas faire masse
de tout de s'interroger précisément sur
les causes mais de bien c'est vous qui
pouvez nous donner cette analyse voilà
Monsieur Miss je suis déjà beaucoup trop
long il y aura sans doute des questions
de la part des collègues mais nous avons
donc je vous le rappelle mes chers
collègues une heure de temps
merci monsieur le Président comme à
chaque fois que bien sûr une commission
des lois m'invite à expliquer l'élection
du gouvernement j'y réponds
favorablement je m'en excuse si vers 18h
comme je vous l'ai dit je vous demande
de quitter votre commission car je
préside d'autres réunions de sécurité
puisque si la situation est calme elle
est à surveillée comme vous l'avez dit
vous-même monsieur le Président après
ces moments extrêmement difficiles
le mardi 27 juin
2023 à 8h16 avenue Frédéric et Irène
Joliot-Curie à Nanterre des effectifs de
la DOPC c'est-à-dire le service de
l'ordre public et de la circulation la
préfecture de police ont voulu procéder
au contrôle d'un véhicule avec trois
individus à son bord qui circulaient
manifestement sur une voie de bus le
conducteur de la voiture voiture
immatriculée en Pologne mais non signal
et volée a refusé d'obtempérer d'après
le rapport de la police nationale aux
injonctions des policiers puis est finie
par couper le contact passage François
Arago à Nanterre le conducteur a alors
manifestement suitement redémarré
le fonctionnaire de police comme tout le
monde l'a vu sur cette vidéo a fait
usage à une reprise de son arme
administrative il s'agissait d'un
policier expérimenté de 38 ans qui ne
connaissait aucune difficulté dans son
casier qu'elle avait été décorée à
plusieurs reprises il est accompagné par
un autre policier expérimenté de 40 ans
qui lui aussi ne connaissait pas de
difficultés particulière avec son
administration les véhicules a fini sa
course encastrant dans une barrière et
un poteau le conducteur qui
manifestement a été blessé au thorax
était en arrêt cardio respiratoire les
effectifs de police qui sont arrivés en
prodigué un premier massage cardiaque
avant l'arrivée des serpents du Samu qui
ont pris de relais mais le conducteur
blessé a été déclaré des CD à 9h15 le
premier passager arrière toujours dans
le véhicule a été immédiatement
interpellé le deuxième passager non
identifiant des faits a pris la fuite il
a depuis chacun la vue était identifié
c'est-à-dire exprimé dans les médias il
a été contrôlé dans la nuit du samedi
1er juillet en violation d'un contrôle
judiciaire sur ses horaires de sortie
est placé en rétention judiciaire il a
été remis à l'issue de la mesure à ses
civils en responsables puisque il était
comme le conducteur non majeur au moment
des faits le procureur de la République
a saisi l'instruction générale de la
police nationale et nous avons fait
pareil en administratif au même moment
et cela en mené l'enquête vous avez vu
qu'ils ont mis en garde à vue les
policiers le policier qui a utilisé son
tir administratif au bout de 48 heures
le policier était présenté devant des
magistrats instructeurs une information
judiciaire était ouverte il a été mis en
examen et placé en détention provisoire
et m'appartient pas plus en amont de
discuter évidemment de l'enquête
judiciaire ni des suites judiciaires ce
sera évidemment
au parquet ou à la chancellerie de
communiquer à la suite évidemment de cet
événement absolument dramatique pour
lequel je crois très rapidement le
gouvernement a fait transparence et à
utiliser me semble-t-il les mots qu'il
convenait tout en rappelant que ce
policier a le droit comme toute personne
à la présomption innocence qui n'est pas
condamnée définitivement il y a eu une
nuit celle qui a suivi immédiatement qui
aurait pu être une nuit de désordre
public et je voudrais ici dire que le
ministère de l'Intérieur s'est préparé
immédiatement au fait qu'il pouvait
avoir des manifestations et donc il a
mis en place un dispositif d'ordre
public et cette manifestation ces
manifestations n'ont pas eu lieu puisque
ce que nous avons constaté de la
première nuit ce sont des violences
urbaines à Nanterre c'est tout à fait
vrai mais dans d'autres villes de France
par effet de mimétisme de très
certainement on y reviendra et donc la
posture du ministère de l'Intérieur qui
était évidemment d'éviter un autre drame
passer à ma demande d'une position
d'ordre public à une position de lutte
contre les violences urbaines ce qui
explique à la fois la mobilisation de
moyens extrêmement différents mais aussi
la stratégie a mis en place par les
préfets sous mon autorité et
singulièrement par le préfet de police
même s'il n'a pas été le seul au
rendez-vous bien sûr de cette action je
voudrais en remercier ici les préfets
les équipes de direction générale de la
police nationale la gendarmerie
nationale de la Préfecture de Police de
la DGSI qui a été également mobilisé
l'ensemble bien sûr des forces de
l'ordre y compris des sapeurs et des
prédices municipales qui ont contribué à
ce travail nous avons connu pendant ces
moments très difficiles donc je peux
compter ce moment difficile entre le 27
juin et aujourd'hui monsieur le
Président même si les deux dernières
nuits ont été extrêmement calmes
23878 feux de voie publique et
saguillèrement des poubelles
12031 véhicules incendiés
2508 bâtiments incendiés ou dégradés
dont 273 bâtiments qui appartiennent aux
forces de l'ordre police nationale
gendarmerie ou police municipale vers
les pays municipales ont payé à l'autre
tribu à ces attaques inacceptables 105
mairies incendies ou dégradées 168
écoles on fait l'objet d'attaque quelle
qu'elle soit et sur la même période 17
atteintes aux élus ont été recentrés par
le mystère de l'Intérieur donc bien sûr
le cas de Monsieur le Maire de l'Aïd les
roses évidemment devant une violence
extrêmement forte et devant une posture
d'interpellation sont exigées par mes
soins
les services de la police nationale
gendarmerie ont procédé à 3500 5
interpellations dont 1373 dans la seule
zone de la préfecture de police
c'est-à-dire Paris et sa petite couronne
du notamment au fait que nous avons
demandé comme chacun a vu dès le
deuxième jour que les brigades
d'intervention qui d'habitude sont
utilisés en judiciaire je parle du raid
du GIGN de la Berry ou des pelons de la
gare de républicaine ont été mobilisés
dans toutes les villes de France et on
procédé à ces très nombreux
interpellations je crois dans des
conditions conformes à la loi et à la
déontologie et aux principes de
proportionnalité que je leur ai demandé
même s'il peut y avoir des moments
dramatiques et évidemment on entend ici
ou là le fait que cela puisse exister il
n'y a à ma connaissance que 10 saisies
de l'IGPN ou de l'iggn dans des cas
particuliers pour l'instant pour lequel
je n'ai que très peu d'informations et
pour le cas d'ailleurs des enquêtes
judiciaires te sont ouvertes je vais
donc remercier les policiers des
gendarmes puisqu'ils ont agi dans des
conditions difficiles on les a rappelé
de leur congés on a annulé des
formations on a rappelé des missions
comme les CRS des plages pour que bien
évidemment puissent répondre à cette
problématique on a organisé des
continuités de service qui était au-delà
des horaires je saurai monsieur le
Président en tant que chef
d'administration Miss à l'intérieur les
remercier symboliquement et plus que
cela évidemment pour cette mobilisation
parce que c'est leur mobilisation et
leur professionnalisme qui a permis de
rassurer les élus limiter les attaques
même si elles ont été extrêmement
nombreuses et je veux le dire ici
augmenter un nombre d'interpellations
jamais retenues qui a permis une réponse
pénale qui je crois est forte même si je
n'ai pas tous les chiffres et que on
sait tous que la réponse pénale met du
temps après les interpellations et les
garde à vue continuez à travailler de
police judiciaire je reviendrai monsieur
le cadre monsieur le Président la
Commission des lois parce que nous avons
évidemment à travailler en judiciaire
pour pouvoir interpeller dans la journée
tous ceux qui commettaient les méfaits
la nuit et ça contribuer très largement
me semble-t-il au calme juré quelques
exemples à vous donner et en confiant la
police judiciaire je voudrais dire à
Monsieur Durand peut-être avec facétie
simuler en préfigurant la réforme de la
police nationale nous avons su je crois
retrouver énormément de monde et
notamment énormément interpellé de
personnes dans la journée tellement
assigne partie des ardeurs des émeutiers
et des délinquants et nous avons su me
semble-t-il protéger quelques symboles
extrêmement forts et nous avons vu
transformer finalement ce mouvement qui
était des mouvements d'attaque
évidemment c'est un peu caricatural
parce qu'il faut regarder territoire par
territoire des attaques symboles de la
République école commissariat mairie
brigade de gendarmerie poste de police
municipale centre socio en pillage de
commerçants qui étaient la deuxième
phase si j'ose dire de cette de cette
série de nuit extrêmement extrêmement
difficile en quelques mots monsieur le
monsieur le président 45 000 forces de
l'ordre ont été mobilisées l'intégralité
je l'ai dit des forces ministères de
l'Intérieur elle va très retravailler
les services de renseignement une très
bonne collaboration non seulement le
commissaire de la justice mais avec les
procureurs de la République qui ont su
je crois être au rendez-vous de la
travail très important fait par la
police et par la gendarmerie mais une
sociologie qui interroge la sociologie
des délinquants des émeutiers interroges
sur ces 3500 interpellations j'ai
l'occasion de dire la moyenne d'âge
entre 17 et 18 ans elle a tendance à
augmenter un tout petit peu puisque
aujourd'hui ce que nous faisons c'est
que nous allons chercher un
interpellation des personnes qui ont été
soit par les travaux d'enquête
technologiques que chacun comprendra ici
récupérer des personnes un petit peu
plus âgées mais le dernier comptage que
j'avais c'est que la dernière la
première personne qui a été interpellée
à 11 ans et la dernière à 59 ans et que
si il y a une moyenne de 17 à 18 ans
pour ce qu'on a arrêté et que un tiers
et mineur vous aurez donc compris que
les mineurs que nous avons sont
extrêmement jeunes pour la plupart pour
la plupart d'entre eux comme j'ai dit
aux questions gouvernement monsieur le
Président nous pouvons constater par
ailleurs que à notre connaissance seule
10% des personnes que nous avons
interpellées sur de nationalités non
françaises et d'ailleurs il y a eu 40
placements en centre de rétention
administrative ce qui est peu à vous le
sur 3500 personnes interpellées je
voudrais aussi souligner que comme j'ai
dit tout à l'heure à ma connaissance 60%
des personnes que nous avons
interpellées n'ont pas de casier
judiciaire et ne sont pas connues des
services de police
cette évidemment difficile d'aller plus
au delà de la sociologie de ces
personnes puisque après les
interpellations
ces personnes sont rentrées dans un
fichier qui s'appelle casiopée qui a
affiché judiciaire et il appartient sans
doute à monsieur le garde des sceaux
donner des informations dans quelques
jours je vois que c'est un peu trop tôt
pour qu'il puisse le faire sur la
composition exacte des personnes pour
que nous comprenions leur origine
géographique et des motivations
éventuelles qui les ont amenés à
commettre
aujourd'hui monsieur le Président la
posture du ministère de l'intérieur
c'est évidemment d'être extrêmement
attentif ça repose sur trois grands
piliers le premier c'est une présence
des forces de l'ordre extrêmement forte
sur le territoire national je constate
avec vous que ni l'accord ni les
outre-mer à quelques exceptions près un
peu la Guyane un peu la Réunion mais
très en deçà de ce qu'a fait la
métropole donc il s'agit d'un sujet
exclusivement métropolitain ou quasi
suivant métropolitain rester très
éveillés donc pour la présence de voies
publiques et notamment la nuit
je constate